la dimension européenne est également
recherché par coluche il est venu
aujourd'hui à strasbourg devant le
parlement européen
plaider la cause des restaurants du
coeur sa visite n'est pas passée
inaperçue qui arrive qu à l'iso je crois
que j'aurais dû me saper at il dit sûr
que la tenue qu'il arborait ce matin au
parlement n'est pas de celles que l'on a
coutume de poortere ici encore que bien
des dames et trouver l'ensemble seyant
et les ongles vernis du plus beau rose
fidèle à lui-même coluche n'est pas
passée inaperçue et a réussi une
nouvelle fois à déplacer du monde
histoire de rappeler qu'il existait 600
restaurants du coeur qui distribue et
120 mille repas chaque jour qui coûtait
désormais 5 francs pièce histoire aussi
de dire aux européens qu'ils doivent
utiliser intelligemment leurs excédents
histoire enfin de rappeler ces les moins
riches qui sont les plus généreux que
les politiques de tous bords cherche à
récupérer le mouvement
coluche n'en a cure en revanche ce qu'il
attend de l'europe était savoir ce qu'on
est venu vous demander en tout cas ce
qu'on est venu dire ici c'est qu'il
faudrait que ça s'élargissent à la
communauté que tous les pays pour les
déshérités qui n'ont pas à manger
puissent avoir accès à ces excellentes
productions qui finalement très souvent
sont détruits